there are many ways to gain users but in
the beginning a promotional offer or
incentives are great tools there are
many different types of promotional
offers you can use to attract new users
if you have an app that people need to
pay for you can offer a free trial to it
if it's a free app you can offer a
premium version for example with
abarkment we offer the app for free but
maybe we can give them their first
booking without any fees there's so many
options you could host a giveaway for a
service or a product related to your app
you can offer discounts to products or
services you offer you can give away
bonus points that they could use for
something else on your site you can even
come up with a special offer for
referring someone new you and a friend
$10 off your next order the bottom line
is you want to get people excited enough
about the offer so they share it and
once your promotion is on social
channels or in a press release it's more
likely to go viral and attract more
users to your app now it's really wise
to track your promotions that you're
offering that way you can figure out
what promotions work the best and give
you the most return on investment you
can use this by tracking a discount code
people use or using something like
Google Analytics to track traffic to
your site after you release the
promotion we're going to cover analytics
more in lesson 5 but we want to get you
in the mindset of measuring everything
you can that way you can make future
decisions based on your results now
let's see what Noam has to say about
promotional offers and incentives to
gain users